[Musique]
d'abord et on a qui sortent leurs
cousins goguette de passes championnat
qui fait menée aux états unis au
michigan travail avec le no 6 heures
c'est le laki mineurs de réduire de 3 on
a 4 3 dans la collecte contre les 12 ans
et moins s'est trouvé que les femmes qui
ont plus de succès dans la vie ont
souvent joué dans des sports d'équipé
quand il était plus jeune
donc je présidais d'aider ces jeunes
filles à avoir une meilleure chance de
performer dans leur vie
[Musique]
quant à certains que l'acquis pour moi
c'était des relations de ma vie il ya
beaucoup de choses que j'ai pris dans la
quille me faire pas tranché disney qui a
peu à voir revenir peut travailler
parfois c'est de faire l'équipe
surtout que j'étais la seule pique quand
j'étais jeune le plus de monde sinon
fallait que je travaille plus parfois
que je trouve qu est ce que j'étais
capable de faire
c'est pas mal une des choses les plus
difficiles en étant gardé le but est la
dernière personne toutes les héros se
boit mais c'est aussi la raison pourquoi
choisir un gardien de but être sur un
niveau de stress tellement élevé puis de
terminer la partie qui savoir que tu as
fait la différence dans une partie
s'était c'est un feeling qui est
incroyable
[Musique]
c'est certain que ça m'a aidé à devenir
beaucoup plus forte
puis de croire en moi puis de presser
les gens qui me disent qu'elles sont
capables de faire je me souviens la
journée que j'étais à tampa bay y ait
beaucoup de monde qui vont te papa
d'avoir la pole petit peu ça mais je me
suis dit il ya tellement de gens de la
vie qui m'ont dit non parce que j'étais
une fille j'avais une chance d'aller
jouer au plus haut niveau que je me suis
dit le pire si ça marche pas ça marche
comme au moins doit avoir essayé
le fait que j'étais capable de performer
avec tout ce stress là sa tête la
victoire encore plus élevé pour moi
avoir la chance de gagner sa vie en
faisant le sport fait t'adore que j'ai
fait toute ma vie j'étais passionné qui
peuvent commander mieux que ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est important pour moi c'est en deux
points pour aider déjà financièrement
avec ma fondation qui porte mon nom pour
les jeunes qui veulent justement aller
au collège que ce soit lui ou un autre
sport
[Musique]
d'avoir joué c'était incroyable mais de
savoir que je fais la différence dans
l'air la vie de jeune fille ça c'est ce
qui était le plus satisfaisant pour moi
[Applaudissements]